要看两个广告才可以听
气死我了
这不是我的歌吗
耍官威
我都差点滚下去哇
拥有这个最好的单品
而且他这个崩的时候
他他的屁崩
他的公公也崩了
在选内所有老师
你现在在想我吗
老师
他教我的时候可以这样啊
哎呦哦
我觉得很可爱
哈哈哈哈哈可爱了
而且你最后没有看到他这赞赞对他是这哈哈
我又想要放在没有
现在没有机啊
再讲一次
那天我们围圆圈圈的时候
台下有叫诶
♪ 哦当当当咚咚当当当当当当当当当当 ♪
原来我不知道啊
我想说嗯是怎么样
张姐说可能是因为很冤
因为昨天好像真的很冤
那就大家要维持那么圆咯
要圆到圆到大家会教的那个我们自己要啊
听着呼吸和成病人就怕爱一天天梦嘴臭什么啊
一点点风吹脚下
嘿嘿转身真是火大
真的很奇怪
他说了算哈哈哈
他是我们的局管
他就用耍官威
当哈哈哈
双官威害
我在那个阳明山上斜坡上拿的那个棒子
那边锤我都差点滚下去
这是我们的存折哥精心设计的
来看一下我们那个回收再利用
这个羽毛是其中一站的花篮里面
♪ 棒棒棒棒棒棒棒棒棒 ♪
♪ 巴拉蹦蹦蹦蹦蹦哒啦 ♪
♪ 蹦蹦蹦蹦蹦蹦蹦蹦巴拉蹦蹦 ♪
♪ 美丽的你还自在 ♪
当年的模样总是很难有祭奠
我不要被你们拉走
这次不认的
♪ 难道遗忘记心的渴望 ♪
别对你伤口了脚
♪ 不专心虚妄 ♪
♪ 不吹头的想念 ♪
♪ 不准回头坐下 ♪
你就好
都给你们唱啊
恋爱还有多什么
经过我的深度迷恋着我后面的朋友
二楼上楼上的朋友
不好意思哦
这实在是太会唱了
时间发怎么这么大声
♪ 循环之舞 ♪
Three two
总有昨天你有被观众吓到吗
太热情了
我不会吓到
我觉得很棒
觉得嘿过儿
你想必你们也是吧
华社群的那些吼叫声
我真的不禁也笑出来了
这带给了我们很多很大的情绪价值
谢谢你们只是为独
♪ 我将自己漫步 ♪
交出我最深处
换一些温度
♪ 哀乐喜怒都是好的感触 ♪
♪ 历经破碎又重组 ♪
♪ 才能变得丰富啊 ♪
心灵姐姐你好呀
我是一个视力障碍的你的粉丝
我叫学平嗯
非常开心
在3月30号
我人生当中的第一场演唱会去看了你的表演哇
那天真的是非常的精彩
也非常的开心
我到现在我感觉每天想起来
我都觉得那天的时光是最难忘的
那在这里呢
也祝我们心灵姐姐后续的巡演能够成功啊
而且顺利
然后到时候我也会在网络上关注你的演
唱会视频哟
OK我刚刚在后台呢跟大家分享一下
我看到了一个宣传组同事给我看了一个呃
应该是有一点视障
然后来看演唱会
然后跟我就是呃分享说呃
他就是啊看我们的演唱会就是有多开心
他觉得很精彩
也听说就是他们来的路途中
他们好像也是就是在路上要问警察
奉公安呐
然后很可爱的
就是听说有一些领导们看到他们
就是是是把他们带上座位的
我觉得这样的爱着这个传播的力量很好
所以我们呃一样
所以我每次在台上的演出其实都很重要
我们能够把我们的爱跟我们的能量带给他们
让他们在呃每每一次来这个演出的时候
那个内心的满满的感觉
只要想到这一晚
他们就可以继续很温暖
很开心的继续嗯
热爱他们的生命
你哭了真的好感动
一定要拿出最好的朋友
然后把这个呃呃让他们保持热爱
这个能量继续就是延续下去
好没问题
♪ 睫毛弯弯 ♪
♪ 眼睛眨啊眨 ♪
♪ 心动的世界 ♪
玩